welcome back to new rock stars this is
big question the show that gives you too
much information about which
incarcerated mcu villain
is buying up all the instant ramen
noodles at the prison commissary
that's some real inside baseball right
there whoever wrote that joke
understands prison culture i love it
all right speaking of prison
i just broke out the greatest hosting
talent we've had and we're putting a
crew together
for one last job cause with me today i'm
tommy beckham of course
and i'm here today with my man so nice
we had to do it twice
back together again this dream team is
with us today
people call us that's our that's our
name peaches and cream
but whenever we are together it's like
oh my god it's peaches and cream on new
rock stars
we were a wrestling tag team peaches and
cream would be what i would go for
oh god maybe not that sounds very
suggestive maybe something else
but i'm down for it hey whatever ass uh
all right
it's already started okay ah let's get
to the show
on falcon and winter soldier we saw
baron zemo peacefully take a ride from
the dora moulage
to his new incarcerated home on the raft
and that got us thinking about our big
question of the week
so here it is empty which mcu villains
are still locked up
and poised to make a big return in the
future that's a great question because
now that zemo is headed back to prison
at the raft via dora melange airlines
we can only assume that another prison
break awaits our favorite
sokovian baron this has us wondering
what
other mcu villains that we have met
before are out there
whether waiting for someone to spring
them from prison or bring them in from a
life
on the run for this big question we're
not looking
at villains who are assumed to be dead
slash permanently gone
and could somehow magically make their
return or reappear such as
red skull darren cross the yellow jacket
that we saw
very disturbingly die in ant-man 1
potentially and whiplash or aldrich
killian no
these are villains that are just doing
their time in the pokey or just
laying low waiting to come back and get
to work on some new nefarious deeds
now let's start off with some
incarcerated villains shall we
let us start with the jail folk first
off
zemo and he's headed to the raft of
course which is the famous underground
prison that we see in captain america
civil war
and it's a prison for those who are
biologically or technologically advanced
primarily
and like we're not 100 sure as to its
location within the mcu
but um it's probably somewhere in the
atlantic ocean since
in the comics the raft is placed near
rikers island in new york city or
in general not just that's a good
question you know i was thinking about
that
i was wondering if we're going to see
zemo in the next
we got one more episode left right by
the time this airs we'll have this
question answered so i don't know if
this chime in will make any sense but
yeah it'll be interesting to see
how the uh the show wraps up zemo's
storyline
yeah and if we even have him in the raft
for an extended period of time
or if he's just dropping by for a quick
visit like my cousins who would go to
jail on weekends
just to stop by say hi to the friends
you know friends and family
that was a little issue yeah exactly
then i just break out
uh before monday you know like that's a
nice little
weekend plan i should go to prison i
should just go to prison this weekend
just say hi
you know we can avoid it
now we can assume that there are some
other enhanced villains at the raft some
we've yet to meet in the mcu
and potentially some we have already
been introduced to but for now the only
villain that we really can be for
certain is on the raft is
zemo so and then there's also emil
blonsky the abomination if you remember
from the 2008 uh incredible hulk film
with edward norton who is not mark
ruffalo but
also play the incredible hulk at one
point if you are a child
you probably don't remember but it's
it's an important part of our marvel
history so
yes you should watch it read your books
and watch your old movies
seriously just like black and white 2008
just
amazing era just kidding though now
according to agents of shield the last
known location of abomination is in a
cryo cell at a shield facility called
the vault in barrow alaska and while
agents of shield
isn't necessarily considered canon in
the mcu
kevin feige didn't confirm in 2017 that
the abomination is
in a prison somewhere so who knows well
i i think that makes sense though
because we
we don't have a lot i mean we have
thunderbolt ross from that movie
but other than that like i think marvel
probably due to the fact that
they parted ways with edward norton
whether it was a mickable and just you
know
creative vision thing they haven't
really carried a lot of other things
from that movie over as
yeah whereas like you know usually these
movies are mined for like every little
precious resource they have that can be
brought back in a
you know a deleted scene or a
post-credit scene like
so far that the 2008 hulk remains a uh
a wealth of of things we could uh we
could we could
reintroduce into the mcu so i look
forward to that i hope no
yeah for sure i feel like kevin feige
was like for a long time anyway because
the first incredible hulk movie
had edward norton and it didn't really
do all that well he was just like let's
pretend it really didn't happen
like let's just introduce a new hulk and
just forget about it what you got there
it's a smoothie when roz came in with um
you know
civil war and all that and you know
they're starting to slowly reintroduce
elements of that movie so
when we do see um emil blonty again it
will be really dope
to actually get some some of incredible
hulk
of visibility because uh i'm tired of
all the incredible hulk erasure
um i don't know what i'm saying anyway
moving forward here we go
and speaking of that kevin feige quote
it came in response to a question about
abomination
and another potential mcu villain samuel
stearns
aka the leader now the last we saw of
samuel stearns was his big ol throbbing
head
after being infected with bruce banner's
irradiated blood now comic fans will
recognize samuel stearns as the leader
a hulk villain with a genius level
intellect telekinesis and telepathy
powers
all thanks to that big old noggin and
it's quite big
and it is very disturbing to look at
when it's when it's moving
around it's i wish i had that excuse for
why my head is so huge
when i was obviously the same i have a
big black
melon here and it was a radiant wear
baseball hats for the most part i wish
there was something
that they had powers to offset that
embarrassment you know how bad i want to
wear a snapback
i'm dying to wear a snapback you know
what i could move things with my mind
exactly that would be clutch you know
what big head gang
we gonna be moving in 2021 you know
that's the goal big head game
oh my god so suggestive getting big head
from peace
you can only watch this after midnight
the following program is rated tv
m-a-l-s-v
now according to the limited series
comic the avengers prelude
fury's big week natasha romanov found
samuel stern in the lab
while monitoring bruce banner and took
him into shield custody where he could
be
or whether or not he's still in shield
custody remains to be seen
but we'll see what happens i mean i'm
personally very much looking forward to
seeing more of the leader um i've
i thought that the leader was behind a
couple of things in the mcu in the past
but it turns out
it wasn't the leader so i feel like
we'll be seeing the leader very soon yes
yes we're owed we're owed some leader
action we're owed some leadership
following the leader the leader the
leader
and of course there's also one of
everyone's favorite mcu villains
of all time the vulture from spider-man
homecoming adrian tombs aka the vulture
was last seen serving time in prison
like we don't get a confirmation of
which prison he's at i mean possibly
rikers island but
wherever he is they sure have some nice
white
uniforms and now at the end of the
morbius trailer we actually get a brief
glimpse of michael keaton who plays
adrian toombs who appears to still be
wearing the very same
white uniform possibly being transported
to another facility
now we'll have to wait and see what
happens in that film but until then we
have to mention
another prisoner tombs runs into you
which is of course scorpion
by my favorite actor from far cry 3.
um i forget his name but um
i love him i love him he's a great actor
matt gargan who comic book readers will
recognize as a spider-man villain
scorpion while we haven't seen him don
the mechanical
poisonous tale quite yet we have to
imagine that marvel could introduce
scorpion
in the near future i mean dreams and
gargan could potentially escape together
but it didn't really look like they were
getting along too well at the end of
spider-man homecoming so
maybe not that's right i can't i need
more adrian tombs in my life though
oh my god yes he was such a great bad
guy in that movie i
i yeah more more more please like i fell
for him like you genuinely feel for that
character it's like oh damn
yeah they're doing such a great job in
those movies of making the villains
pretty three-dimensional for the most
part and so you're like oh man like
this guy's not so bad gonna see
murderous people
it's fine he only murdered the original
stalker in cold blood
it's totally fine i mean to be fair he
didn't know it was gonna do that
that's true that is very true it's an
accident so
you know if murder is an accident it's
fine
did i do that don't forget him i don't
want to go no
murder we don't condone murder this is a
this is a anti-murder
show yes we're strictly anti-murder here
um if you're pro murderer sorry you're
gonna have to unsubscribe
sorry haters sorry
sorry life haters we just love life here
blocking out the haters
and of course we have to mention justin
hammer now we last seen the tony stark
foil
at seagate penitentiary in the all hail
the king marvel one shot and of course
seagate is a prison located on an island
off the coast of georgia and justin was
locked up with another ironman villain
by the name
of mandarin but not the real mandarin
just like the fake
actor mandarin played by trevor slattery
who was played by
ben kingsley which is great and i love
him
that voice i had forgotten i i just
rewatched that movie recently
i had forgotten that that's the voice
ben kingsley did for that character
oh man this is truly incredible
we don't talk enough about this before
right yo when that trailer came out the
iron man 3 trailer i was like yo this is
going to be
bonkers but then you know ben kingsley
ended up playing
trevor you know which was kind of a
letdown but like i just loved ben
kingsley's performance so much that i
was like i don't really care it's
i'm whatever and we expect to see the
mandarin in the upcoming shongxi
film and we do see him in the shogi
trailer with wenwu
who was playing shanxi's father who is
also
um very much implied to be the mandarin
himself and of course we gotta talk
about
sunny birch from ant-man and the wasp
now the last time we saw sunny burch the
restauranteur
and black market technology dealer he
was spilling his guts to the sfpd after
being injected with the truth serum
at the end of ant-man and the wasp now
sonny does have connections to the fbi
so he may have been
transitioned over to their custody but
was he the mysterious person in witness
protection
in one division that we never really get
to see probably not
but we're pretty sure that the fbi has
plenty of questions for him after he was
apprehended so
and also finally speaking of west view
we gotta talk about
agatha harkness one of the sassiest
witches that you will ever see
now agatha archivist is currently locked
away in in a prison
of her own mind in west view after the
events of one division after
wanda really just messed her up and just
made her a prison of the town
and now i'm pretty sure we'll be seeing
agatha harkness again but i don't know
if anyone other than the scarlet witch
herself can release agatha from her
mental prison i mean maybe doctor
strange but i have a feeling that you
know
we've got scarlet witch magic i can't
wait till we get back to more agatha but
that is
it for villains in custody but what
about those busy villains who are just
on the run somewhere villains like baron
mordo now
as mordo runs around the world getting
rid of sorcerers and crippling
basketball players for some reason
we expect to see him again in doctor
strange and the multiverse of madness
but it's possible
he could pop up somewhere else in the
mcu that's a slow burn for a bad guy too
because
he spent the whole first doctor strange
movie not being a bad guy
he was like yeah he was a good guy he
was a good guy he just went up on
benjamin bratt and ruined his day at the
end
seeing that turn at the end of doctor
strange one where he just cripples that
guy
i'm just like oh my god you love a
villain that's like
motivation is that the protagonist is
just such a jackass
i have to become a diabolical evil man
because doctor strange is so
insufferable right it's like you're just
a dick so you you made me you're
responsible for me yeah
why are you doing this too many
sorcerers two villains that people don't
really think about are
shocker and tinkerer from spider-man
homecoming they're both unaccounted for
obviously after the events of spider-man
homecoming but they could be out there
doing some low-level crime
or potentially coming up with a scheme
to bust their old boss out of prison
because
oh yes it would make sense because tombs
was the brains of the operation
so it'd be kind of hard for them to just
do their own thing after
making so much mula off of that sweet
chitari tech but another villain that
could still be out there is of course
ghost from ant-man in the watts now the
last time we see ghost she was waiting
on some healing quantum energy from
scott lang and dr pym but then that
whole
you know thanos snapping everyone yeah
half the people out of existence thing
happened it did get in the way of her
getting
that sweet quantum energy now has she
said goodbye to her nefarious ways or
is she back to the bad side after being
stood up because she never got that
quantum energy and she needs it to
not fall apart which is great to do when
you're a human being not falling apart i
highly recommend it i emotionally fall
apart every morning and of course we
can't talk about
villains without talking about the
greatest villain of all time
zola zola is definitely out there
somewhere in the mcu i'm sure that
there's a hard drive or a usb stick with
some zola code on it
i personally believe that when captain
america yanked that
usb stick towards the middle of captain
america the winter soldier
that there was a copy of zola on that
usb stick and that he went
out but that's just me but if anyone
could find zola it would be recently
escaped from the raft baron zemo
i mean it's very likely because zemo had
that book
and he had a lot of knowledge about
hydra stuff so it's just like
hmm great job a very comprehensive list
and of course mt we don't know the
plethora of villains that could be
coming our way if the multiverse is
introduced
maybe even x-men would anybody be mad if
a fast bender showed up i wouldn't
so coming up we're going to dive into
our bite-sized questions but first
a word from some of the folks that help
us bring you big question
as lots of the world is starting to edge
back towards normalcy
we're thinking about going out into the
world and looking good while we do it
that's right it's time to cut your hair
go to the gym put on some smooth
smelling lotions some colognes some
fragrances
it's time to get fit and lit folks and
hey for that there's cuts clothing
they've taken a classic men's fashion
staple the plain tee
and refined it they're blending timeless
style and comfort so that you look as
good as you feel and baby
i feel good in my cups i love my cups
tea
they're comfortable enough to wear
around the house or while exercising but
stylish enough that i wouldn't feel
weird wearing them to dinner you know
whenever that becomes a thing again and
let me tell you
if you're still wearing button-ups to
your dinner dates in 2021
after a pandemic you are a sucker baby
all right straight up
in 2016 cuts founder steve borelli set
out to make clothes ready for every
occasion
the t-shirt he created made gq magazine
call it the only shirt worth wearing i'm
telling you
i used to go to myrtle beach with my
best friends that we'd make airbrushed
shirts commemorating the greatest
summers of our lives
i threw those shirts in the trash after
i got my cuts
my t-shirt okay cuts is premium
with a purpose each piece is designed
with custom engineered fabric
graded for the perfect fit it's an a
plus in my case
setting you up to look great in any
situation it's not just a lifestyle
it's not just clothing it's office
leisure apparel for the sport of
business help your first order by going
to cutsclothing.com
bigquestion that's cutsclothing.com
bigquestion
for 15 off the only shirt worth wearing
and also this episode is also brought to
you by
amazon pharmacy now amazon pharmacy
delivers medication
right to your door i mean amazon
pharmacy works with most
insurance plans nationwide and they
coordinate with your doctor to receive
your prescriptions
and then they ship them right to you now
i don't know about
you but i'm already on amazon almost
every day like
buying stuff watching shows and movies
on prime
it just makes sense to get prescriptions
through amazon too i mean it's insanely
convenient
no more waiting in line at the pharmacy
and there's one less errand for you to
run
spend that time streaming invincible or
the boys or whatever
especially invincible invisible is great
you should be watching invincible like
running errands and waiting in line
sucks and those shows are great so the
math on how you spend your time
is pretty easy on this one amazon prime
members can save on prescription
medication when not using insurance and
get free
two-day delivery learn more at
amazon.com
bigquestion that is amazon.com
bigquestion amazon.com
big question it's very easy oh i'm
hungry empty
oh i have a rumble in my tummy but i
don't want to eat a whole big meal
before dinner
no no no give me a little something
bite-sized oh
i like that well how about this for a
bite-size
friend do lightsabers work underwater
that was a question from
iaj smith 24 on the discord
oh good question and let me go ahead and
tell you the answer to that
a standard lightsaber won't work
underwater
a standard lightsaber won't work
underwater the crystal circuit is
susceptible to water damage and can
easily short out
however there is an ancient modification
the jedi discovered to circumvent this
problem
a lightsaber can utilize two crystals to
make a bifurcating cyclical ignition
pulse that's right
a bifurcating cyclical ignition policies
by procuring cyclical ignition
the power is cycled between the two
crystals in order to prevent one of them
from shorting out
when the weapon is submerged under water
now the majority of the jedi don't
bother to make this modification on
their lightsaber they don't give a [ __ ]
about it okay
this is generally not necessary for most
jedi that is
however kit fisto is a nautilin this
species is amphibious meaning he can
live on the land
and underwater so he has a bifurcating
cyclical ignition pulse lightsaber
and has been shown in the comics in
clone wars series using the weapon
underwater especially during the first
and second battles of
mon calamari which as we all know are
the most delicious battles in all of the
star wars universe
you get the calamari fried you get it
baked you get it seared over some hot
olive oil it doesn't matter
it's delicious delicious war i like my
general ackbar with the side of tartar
sauce
your tongues can't repel flavor of that
magnitude that is
an excellent answer my friend but here's
another one for you from
a civilian on discord and that question
is
if vibranium came to earth via meteor
where did that meteor come from and is
vibranium used on any other planet
get into that tommy good question
civilian well the short answer is when a
vibranium meteor and planet
really love each other they want to show
each other that love by connecting
uh as we learned in the mcu film black
panther
all the vibranium on earth arrived via a
meteorite made of vibranium that struck
africa millions of years ago
it's never been made clear in the films
or in the comics exactly where the
meteorite came from however we do know
that vibranium exists and is utilized in
other parts of the galaxy
in a 2014 captain marvel comic carol
travels to torfa a planet located on the
outskirts of the spartax empire whose
original inhabitants were wiped out by a
plague
hundreds of years ago wiped out by
plagues it's a little close to home
these days this is actually the same
torfa
we see in the early part of the captain
marvel film in the mcu
in the comic carol is there to aid some
alien refugees when she discovers a
secret
vibranium mining operation it's likely
if this planet is the original source of
vibranium or if torpha
was another victim of a drive-by
vibranium media writing oh
always sad to see struck down in their
prime by a drive-by
but this does show that there is some
more vibranium out there in the universe
it's true i i really hope that we see
more vibranium and different like
planets like season vibranium maybe in
like the squirrel planet or the cree
planet or like maybe even like the shia
planet
there's definitely some more vibranium
out there because there's cosmic rock
now it is time for my favorite part of
the program and it's time for
the box of scraps
for today's question we've got a doozy
that i am going to ask and then answer
first because i already know what you're
going to say and i'm not going to let
you out question me
all right so today's box of scraps
question is what's the
best road trip you've ever taken and if
you don't mind
i'll go first the best road trip i ever
took was the craziest road trip i ever
took and that was driving from
good old rochester new york all the way
to los angeles california dang
in 2008 when i was just a young boy with
a dream
a hollywood dream in my heart i drove by
myself
across the country uh through all of the
majesty of nebraska and colorado
which has a shocking amount of federal
prisons in colorado
i just remember they were like do not
pick hitchhikers up in colorado and i
was like damn because i was picking a
lot up in nebraska and things were going
good
but if i can not those colorado
hitchhikers
i mean i felt like a psychopath i was
driving alone all day staying in hotels
at night
shout out to hotels you know how much i
love you and then
finally i got to burbank where i was
house sitting when i first got here and
my car literally
exploded upon i went to the driveway
the water pump burst oh my gosh
that was a chevy cavalier shout out to a
1999 chevy cavalier for getting me
across that whole
damn country that was that was my number
one road trip what do you got
wow your car died when it needed to it
was like i i got you from a to b
and now it's time for me to give up the
ghost that's right
i like that day that's i could never do
that that's a very long
drive because the only real road trip
i've been on
was during i went to montreal a couple
years back
because i was a bridesmaid in a wedding
it was me and it was a bunch of girls
and they were like hey you want to go to
montreal for our bachelorette
shenanigans i was like sure why not
yes as a bridesmaid it is my duty to be
there
um and so while we were there like
montreal's a beautiful city lots of art
and everything but
one thing about montreal um is that they
have strip clubs i mean at their strip
clubs everywhere obviously
but with montreal um there's a there's
no
no touching rule so anyway i go to the
uh
they all are kmt let's go to a strip
club for a bachelorette thing and i'm
thinking that we're going to an all-male
strip club
because they're all females but we end
up going to an all-female strip club
with females
considering them that was really nice of
them i don't know why
that ended up happening but that's what
happened and that was my first time
going to a strip club and so i go inside
and it's just like so overwhelming
because there's a bunch of naked ladies
everywhere i'm just like
i don't know what to do so i just
ordered my water and so i'm sipping my
water out of my swirly straw because i'm
a grown man
i'm just like ordered by water and like
only like
two or three feet away from me is a man
with a face full of a stranger's ass
because he is getting a lap dance
but his face was uh all up in there and
i was like wow this is a new
world this is a whole new world as uh up
in canada they do it a little different
they do it different they do it
different up there
but the coolest thing about that whole
experience is that
i was like enraptured by the strippers
not because that they were stripping but
because of their
crazy upper body strength and just
strength in general
because like i like you have to be the
most
jacked person to do pole dancing
and it was just so amazing and so like
after like we left and all that stuff
like we left at the same time
as a couple of the strippers and i was
just like oh my god you guys are like so
i got star struck i was like you guys
are celebrities
like you guys just did all that amazing
[ __ ] i could never do that i'm a weak
man
like it's just love man it's i gotta say
hey i go to the strip clubs
for the upper body strength of you i
read playboy for the articles
what do you mean honey i had to go there
i admire their athleticism the same as
going to a football game or anything
like that i'm there for the athletes
plain and simple we have like stripper
brackets
little trading cards like oh i've got a
don ross what says
sapphire blaze
oh my god she's been doing a prolific
amount of lap dances we're going to get
cancelled for this all right
best to get out of this well that's
amazing shout out to the bachelorette
for going to a female strip club i would
have assumed you would have been going
to a place called
like polis or stiffy's or something i
was only prepared for sniffies
but we didn't get us dippies we've all
had a good time at stiffy's
features backed up will be isolated and
sent
out in gift form for years to come
speaking of years to come that's it for
this episode of big question
thank you to mt for joining me in this
episode follow him at mastertainment for
crying out loud follow me at tommy
bechtold follow new rockstar send us
your big questions using
the hashtag big questions subscribe to
this podcast feed
and go ahead and give us a nice rating
and review subscribe to new rockstars
here on youtube
hit that notification bell we love you
everybody come back and see us again
soon
take it easy everybody
[Music]
you